joining us now is the international
trade secretary anne marie trevelyan
good morning to you thanks for joining
us on the program i wonder if i could
get your reaction to that to start with
please um hillary clinton has said if
true it's an utter disgrace what do you
think well as ever with leaked documents
uh you never quite know so let's wait
and see but i'm certainly a woman who
believes uh in choice for women
and when the roe versus wade ruling came
through decades ago now it's sort of
before you're in my time you know it's
sort of part of part of our history that
uh that acceptance that actually women
should uh have control of their bodies
uh was something that set a standard for
the rest of the world
and allowed women uh to be empowered uh
in uh this very very critical way so uh
we'll wait and see clearly it's uh uh
whether this is a true document or not
but i think there will be a great deal
of anxiety
if that seems to be true and i suppose
if it goes to a back to a state by state
level uh the us will uh have to deal
with that
in a different way but we'll all have to
wait and see of course what support or
pressure
could or should the british government
try to put on the us government so these
sorts of laws are you know national
decisions and governments uh you know
need to take decisions they have uh
elected representatives through which
they
share their views and in america like in
many democratic countries
the voice of the people is often heard
and uh
their campaigning uh is usually uh you
know taken through so i i imagine if
there's if this were to come uh to be a
change in in a very long-standing law
that there would be very strong uh
campaigning from uh citizens from across
the u.s now i know that you've been
talking trade haven't you with in your
in your role as international trade
secretary with the u.s just last week
would that potentially be an opportunity
in future for us to express a uk view on
this sort of thing so we don't use our
trade tools which are about you know
buying and selling goods and services
and working together to improve routes
of trail things like through digital
trade um we don't bring in but the you
know the fcdo our foreign office uh
speaks on all matters what you might
call diplomatic i think which is what
you refer to and those those continue
all the time regardless of our trading
relationship our trade relationship with
the u.s is incredibly strong and
long-standing uh and that will continue
to be so but i uh on all matters uh when
there are matters of concern uh then the
foreign office would be the department
that would pick up and but you would
raise those it would be reasonable that
they would potentially uh
mess uh mention it in diplomatic
channels
uh so uh not being in the foreign office
uh i don't know but i think could raise
issues of concern are always raised to
diplomatic channels whatever uh they
might be they're done privately often
because that can be a most effective way
uh of you know setting out the view but
this is a matter of concern i think it's
what i'm trying well i think it's a
matter of of great concern i think to to
all women uh in the us if this is a
rowing back on a you know 50-year
50-year
state of state of of things but uh we'll
have to wait and see whether it's true
or not okay uh we um we've done a deal
not a not a trade deal but we're going
to deal with rwanda as we know we saw
the uh home secretary over there just a
couple of weeks ago um the ruling to
send uh migrants who come across the
channel to rwanda became law last
thursday when when are we going to send
our first migrants to rwanda so as you
say the law has uh now been uh brought
in as an act at the end of uh the
parliamentary session uh so the uh
rwanda policy will now start to be uh
brought into place i don't have a
precise date for the case i can't i
can't tell you that but i know that the
uh home secretary and the team are
working very closely to set this place
one of the things about was it was to be
able to look back since the beginning of
the year so uh those who are being
fooled and put put their lives at risk
uh because of the uh people smugglers
who are uh bringing them across in those
schools just deterred people is the
point i'm trying to make 550 migrants
came across the channel can any of those
that came over the weekend expect to
find themselves in a rwanda so i can't
answer that question because i don't
know who they are but the point of the
pro policy is to make sure that we uh
try and really discourage this activity
because it puts people as it's the
busiest stretch of water the channel an
incredibly dangerous place to be and we
want to make sure
that there are many many legal uh
migration applications
yeah you acknowledge that it's not been
a deterrent yet has it well it's only
literally just coming into place so uh
you know like all things uh takes a
little while to actually uh get all the
processes and i was asking when so and i
don't and i don't have an answer for you
in terms of uh precise dates but uh the
policy has been set out and the home
office are working at pace to bring that
into action because we do not want
people to put their lives at risk being
conned by people smugglers to take uh
take themselves to the sea so we'll find
out in the fullness of time um big day
day after tomorrow local elections what
would you view as a success
so it's a funny set of elections because
it's uh not across the country it's not
all uh councils i was uh supporting uh
some young candidates yesterday uh where
uh some of them are up for election uh
and many of them aren't because that's
how our election system works so i think
there are some places where uh there's
some there's some you know close fights
but i think also in many places
certainly on doors i've been knocking on
there's been a continuing sport that has
a local level because of course these
are all local elections they're at your
council uh people who have got
conservative councils know that they've
got uh you know uh great local services
four times as many potholes filled in in
conservative councils as labels i'm not
talking about potholes what i'm talking
to you about what would you view as a
success so i think uh you know as ever
with local councils elections uh will
win some will lose some uh that's that's
the nature of the beast anyway uh but
also that you know 12 years
there are some 50 seats so i'm not uh
close to the precise detail but i would
expect us to win someone new some that
would be normally expected but what i
think we will see uh is a really strong
showing by conservative voters who want
to come out and demonstrate that they
know that locally run councils run by
and conservatives are better sure and no
matter how poorly or well how poorly
let's say the conservative party does
the prime minister will remain in post
you won't see this as a referendum on
the prime minister no why not
uh because as i say local council
elections in these strangers are not a a
they're not a broad reflection of the
whole you don't get a picture of the
vehicle they're a protest vote a bit
like a by-election well sometimes you
get that but as i say you wouldn't be
able to see that in the whole because
they aren't all-out elections in most
places uh but you know as i say 12 years
into government you do get
as you describe it sometimes a protest
vote and you know that's the beauty of
democracy that's one of the reasons
we're supporting
ukraine as they fight to maintain their
democratic right to be a free nation and
is that something that the party is
preparing for potential protest vote
against the prime minister
uh no not at the moment prime minister
is getting on with the job of uh
delivering uh a whole series of policies
to make our country uh you know move
forward in many ways uh from uh you know
more hospitals and more uh schools
supporting uh our police and nhs by
bringing in uh more amazing young people
wanting to join those organizations and
continuing to get on with the job of
running the country and and defending uh
you know defending democracy and freedom
in a way that in europe we haven't seen
for decades by supporting the
extraordinary ukrainian uh leadership of
uh president zolensky and his amazing
people who are talking about local
politicians russian events yeah we're
talking about domestic politics if i may
uh let me ask you about uh
kierstama and uh beer with kia that
seems to be uh getting a pace um four of
your colleagues i think i'm writing
saying four of your colleagues in some
form um
oliver dowd and nadine doris uh grant
chaps and also the defense secretary all
calling for a further police
investigation into what happened in
durham is that something that you would
lend your support to this morning so
across the piece if there were
concerns raised by
you know
local people on the questions uh of of
lockdown rules then i would hope the
local police had uh investigated richard
holden uh one of the durham mps raised
this because he felt that uh durham
conceptually hadn't investigated it i
understand that there is some work on
going and i would absolutely uh
encourage them to look at it because uh
that's the point we did an extraordinary
thing through covid in terms of the the
the whole of our population genuinely
trying to do their bit and do their best
and i
should further investigate well as i say
i think uh
you should uh look at that look at the
situation and look at it properly in the
same way the metropolitan thing
uh well i don't know but uh it appears
uh not so uh or indeed whether you know
the uh reasoning that they brought
forward now that there seems to be more
uh photographic evidence is one they
want to look at again i would encourage
them to do that because i think that
gives competence to the police we police
by consent in the uk it's an
extraordinary thing we are incredibly
lucky
and we need to make sure that we
maintain uh the trust and respect of our
police because uh they do the right
thing so i hope that they will look at
all that's been brought to them and
reach a concision accordingly can it be
in any way compared to what's happened
in downing street though i mean more
crime committed in downing street given
how many fixed penalty notices have been
uh issued than any other street in
england
so as i say i want would want all uh
police constabularies to look at
anything that's brought to them if they
are concerned and they look uh you know
back against legislation that was
brought in temporarily
and for conclusions to reach as indeed
the metropolitan police have uh in
london
and they have reached their conclusions
so do you think given that durham police
also of course were supposed to be
investigating what happened with dominic
cummings back in april of 2020 should
they look again at that well so again if
more evidence was brought to them than
they should if they felt they have
everything and they you know reach the
judgment accordingly then uh because
they did acknowledge that they they took
his witness statement as what he said in
the downing street garden and he has
subsequently said that he was a little
bit economical with the actuality when
that uh came about he was under pressure
and he did he's changed his story
somewhat since so you know there is more
evidence now so as i say i think as we
police by consent in in the uk that uh
we want our police forces uh to uh do
what they need to do with the evidence
that's brought to them so uh you know i
hope darren considerably will do that um
as things stand today do you think that
this is a resigning matter for sakia
stamina given that she was at an event
that uh broke the rules
as i say i'd like uh donald trump
to look at everything and to if they
felt a fixed penalty notice was uh the
appropriate uh you know uh
statement of of conclusion of it in the
same way the metropolitan police have uh
here for a number of people who were in
uh downing street at events that have
been deemed unsuitable uh then uh what
what i would want to see is is that same
fixed spontaneous i don't think those
are resigning matters uh for anybody i i
hear you but labour came out swinging of
course as we know this was angela rayna
if the chancellor gets a fine does he
have to go as well well i would say so
yeah anyone that's in the government
that decides to break the road pretty
empty front bench at this rate well then
there's plenty other mps out there
what do you think
she's saying that the prime minister and
also rishi sunak had to resign and they
should resign and she can't believe that
they're still in post and as far as
rishi sunak is concerned he says all he
did was he was going to a meeting anyway
and he just got caught up in it he's
taken his medicine and god is fine
what i'm saying to you is that as far as
um we don't know with miss rainer we we
need to investigate that further but as
far as tequila is concerned he was at an
event indoors that was breaking the
knockdown rules at the time
so as i say uh i think the police should
uh now with all the
new evidence to come forward look at it
again and if they consider a fixed
penalty notice uh should be issued uh
then clearly that would be uh the tool
available to them to do so uh i don't
think that is i don't think i don't
think that's a resigning matter
personally what if you get a fixed
penalty notice okay so secure stamp is
the safest houses then
what's the fuss about then well it's
it's a the whole point is about uh the
demonstration uh of uh leadership i
think i wish you next point is a very
important one which is um you know if
the metropolitan police have determined
that that crossover through a door uh
was it was a point of was a point of uh
failure that's the right description uh
then uh they have issued their notice
accordingly and i understand that he has
you know paid it
and you know the matter is closed as far
as he is concerned but uh in the same
way uh that would be a reason for the
police to follow through and to reach a
conclusion uh and then
uh for the you know
uh everyone to be able to uh to to to
move forward i think i mean the prime
minister has been clear so many times
it's a bit of mudslinging as far as i
see here is concerned and you know you
don't think you're not calling for him
to resign even if he does get a fixed
penalty notice so why are we bothering
well no i think what we all want to see
as i say we police by consent in this
country so if uh there is evidence
brought to the police which uh makes
them need to investigate whether or not
uh those uh covert rules were broken
they should do so and uh but he still
shouldn't respond if he did well i think
the situation is too is to clear the
situation up and then move forward what
uh kia chooses to do of course uh as a
result of any uh outcome such as that
would be for him to determine great to
talk to you thanks very much individual
pleasure always appreciate it thank you